the meantime the push continues for
vaccine equity and it gets a shot in the
arm today with another pop-up clinic
and a community that needs it hector
mejia live in north las vegas with a
closer look at this hi hector
hey there alex good morning to you and
this two-day pop-up clinic is happening
here at the mlk junior senior center it
opens
at seven o'clock this morning in an area
that serves the african-american
population
likely a strategic move to boost the
vaccine roll out in communities that are
not getting enough vaccines
and here are the numbers from the
southern nevada health district its
covet 19
vaccine snapshot shows that 41 percent
of vaccines distributed in clark county
have been given to white residents
meanwhile 10 percent have been given to
hispanic residents
and only six percent to african
americans we've learned it's partially
due to vaccine
hesitancy lack of information and no
internet
those challenges are happening
nationwide so this pop-up clinic here at
the mlk junior senior center will be
offering the first round of the pfizer
vaccine to those
70 and older plus frontline and
healthcare workers
it will be open today and tomorrow from
7 a.m to 2 p.m
and keep in mind an appointment is
required and you must qualify
you can book an appointment if you don't
have internet by calling 702-342-8417
and back out here live you can see the
website here several time slots
are still available these time slots are
for tomorrow once you click on one of
them
it then takes you to a different screen
that asks for your information
now if you didn't write anything down
don't worry we have all of this already
posted on our website you can head over
to that site and that is
eighteensnow.com reporting live in north
las vegas this morning hector mejia
8 news now